number one reason I have so much
compassion for everyone else is I have
compassion for myself I'm a human I'm
not a superhero I'll make mistakes
attention is the number one asset
because at the end of the day like isn't
one of the theories like hey fail fast
and like no no that is a slang term for
are you willing to take a chance knowing
it may not work out every one of my
chances I'd prefer to work but I'll take
the booby prize of learning you know
what I mean whereas other people I think
are so scared that if it doesn't work
that it completely represents their
entire self-esteem that they don't even
try cuz why would you risk hurting
yourself so much until you love yourself
you can't love anyone else until you
trust yourself you can't trust anyone
else until you're comfortable with
making mistakes with yourself you can't
be comfortable with others making
mistakes the number one reason I have so
much compassion for everyone else is I
have compassion for myself I'm a human
I'm not a superhero I'll make mistakes